dans la majestueuse ville de bondage
joris coule des jours paisibles avec son
père adoptif alors les enfants allaient
prendre le petit
mais les dofus des yeux de dragon
légendaire suscite toutes les
convoitises
sully tu es de retour qui rumine nom
jean réussite en danger
et emporté le dofus est belle
nous avons un moyen de la contrée car s
auto faut aussi voir
je les cache et là bas dans mon temps
fini les enfantillages dakar a coupé tu
vas finir d'amplificateurs
le flat avec un courant fuir en pétrole
où salle une addition fidèles aksam
ennemis si on lui dira juriste sortir de
sa cachette
il est temps qu'ils apprennent la vérité
ribéry s'est appuyé sur nos lois
quelques vérités
le phénomène dofus enfin au cinéma quand
tout ça sera terminé on pourra être allé
boire un verre tous les deux qu'ils
crèvent